foreign
Esther is with us in Dallas hi Esther
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
um I am calling because
um my husband and I have a few questions
and we don't know which way to head we
started um Financial Peace University at
the beginning of last year and
everything was going great and we paid
about 50 000 in debt so far way to go um
thank you because of some of the things
that were happening with our school
district and whatnot I was a teacher I
decided to quit my job and homeschool my
kiddos starting last summer and
um obviously that put a little bit of a
dent in our debt snowball however my
husband had received an increase which
was making up for my loss of pay
um and everything kind of went out okay
we were able to make ends meet well
recently my husband's company the cut
pay from everybody in their company and
that's going to be about over 20 loss of
income for us going into next month
so it's putting us in a difficult
position it would make things a little
harder what did your husband used to
make
um he was making his take-home pay was
right under a hundred thousand they gave
him a twenty thousand dollar pay cut
twenty percent about 20 of 100 is 20
000. right yes
and what does he do
um he does drafting um
architectural type drafting
okay
well the economy in Dallas is booming
why is this architectural firm cutting
pay for people
that's that's our question as well it's
not they didn't say why
no no and he might be temporarily
um again it's not a Texas based company
so we don't know if that has something
to do with it look for a job
yeah why are you staying in a place cut
your pay twenty percent
in a booming economy
that's what we're looking at yeah um
today
yeah
this is not a theory I mean yeah he's
that that's disres he just got
disrespected
yes they were waving a flag in front of
him to leave
and it's everybody in the company I know
it's not just I know but yeah it's not
they fully anticipate several people
leaving as a result of this cutting
their payroll costs down this is
anticipated this is a strategic move on
their part
they're telegraphing this to you saying
leave and I would oblige
yeah go get a job making 120. if I'm
Healed and I bet he can do it by Friday
if you get on it
yes I think you can
um
yes so we have those in our on our to-do
list for it this week however my
question to you was
um before we started FPU we did
everything stupid that we could do with
our money we were comfortable and we had
the lifestyle supposedly to match it
which was just in our minds not reality
um however since we started our debt
snowball like I said things were rolling
along however right now we are getting a
little bit frustrated that we are
kind of like stuck on the same place for
a long time when you quit your job and
your husband got a 20 pay cut of course
things are tight
yes they are and and my question to you
was should we even consider selling our
house to no you need to get your incomes
back up
what's your house payment
um about 2400 a month it's it's very
good compared to what's going on right
now yeah
so you may be tutoring and subbing
while he gets his income up to 120.
and then the house is not a problem
anymore the house only became a problem
when your incomes went away
yeah am I right house is not even our
biggest issue it's paying everything
else down
well you've already gotten rid of fifty
thousand dollars worth of debt back when
both of you had your incomes
yes so you can sub how much do you have
left Esther in debt
a lot
how much
80 about 200 no about 200k on what
student loans we have a personal loan we
had a HELOC
um
a car loan
yeah
okay how much are student loans
um mine is about 30 000 and my husband
is about twenty thousand right on their
20. okay so 50 in student loans and so
how big is the HELOC
about 80
. okay and that is
um
in addition to your 2400 payment
yes okay you may have a house you can't
afford then yeah
because when you put the payment to
those payments all together on your home
you've now got house payments that are
really getting very high even with your
old incomes
yeah it's about 2 800 which is still
less than what we would be paying in
this bracket in Texas but yeah what do
you uh well no that's not true I mean
it's less than you pay for that house in
Texas but there are cheaper houses in
Dallas
right the um uh so how much do you owe
on your cars
um between the two of them were at 41.
okay give me a breakdown on that
which cars how much
my car is about 31. 600 and my husband
it would be the difference I'm sorry I
don't have it in front of me okay that's
okay yeah so here you know the way I
look at all this stuff is what I would
do if I woke up in your shoes Okay
number one the 20 pay cut activates me
looking for a job immediately and it
activates you doing something for income
you've got a teaching certificate you
can sub you can put you can do some
while you homeschool you can still pull
when it's summer right now technically
so
tutoring absolutely great great money
tutoring really great money tutoring and
I'd pick up a bunch of that and get his
income back up get yours up temporarily
I'd sell the thirty one thousand dollar
car in about 20 seconds
I wouldn't keep it before I sold my
house I would be cleaning off a whole
bunch of this other stuff
and I would be willing to lean into this
because selling a house is expensive
it's expensive to move it's expensive
emotionally uh it's expensive everything
and if you can if the house can be
solved if you can work your way through
this and get rid of these debts and get
your incomes up temporarily for a period
of time to plow on through this then
you're there but if you decide to quit
your job you may have decided to sell
your house you for sure decided to sell
your car
you maybe didn't mean to but those
decisions all came together because of
the math
they they were they were knitted
together you couldn't get rid of them
they're tied to each other so
that's the deal I'd sell your car and
I'd get better jobs immediately and
really by Friday
you can do that and all of a sudden the
situation starts to move around give
yourself a little breathing room and
then you can decide later on the house